ja ich habe es ja auch runtergeladen
einfach auch um sie auszuprobieren
letztendlich bin ich ja schon mit der
infektion durch und kann natürlich
keinen nennenswerten beitrag mehr dazu
liefern aber ich möchte sie natürlich
ausprobieren und testen und sehen wie
das ganze funktioniert also wenn man
wenn man die ganzen bedenken noch im ohr
hat und wenn man sieht was da jetzt
passiert ist also über eine million
innerhalb weniger stunden dann scheint
es eine große bereitschaft in der
bevölkerung zu geben dabei mitzumachen
hat sie das überrascht ja so ein
bisschen schon weil im vorfeld sehr viel
diskussion auch ja gerade wegen
datenschutzrechtlicher bedenken
und weil wir uns jetzt auch was die
infektion angeht in der situation
befinden wo er doch nicht so viele
neuinfektion mutter kam und man
vielleicht über den sinn und
sinnhaftigkeit dieses späten erscheinens
diskutieren kann mir aber ich finde es
erfreulich dass das doch so gut
angenommen wird ich hoffe das bleibt so
ist eben ob das der erste hype ist für
id die gierig auf diese app gewartet
habe die sich jetzt sofort anmelden also
aus anderen ländern die eine krone at
bereits haben weiß man kein kein land
hat die nötige quote erreicht man sagt
ja ungefähr 60 prozent müssten dass sich
runterladen um einen effekt zu haben das
hat bisher kein land geschafft aber
vielleicht ist deutschland ja das erste
land das diese quote erreicht
sie sind unzufrieden mit diesem projekt
der stürmer warum
ja ich bin ein bisschen unzufrieden aus
aus zweierlei gründen ich hätte gerne
früher gehabt natürlich weil gerade im
zuge der lockerung wäre es sehr wichtig
gewesen ein zusätzliches instrument zu
haben wenn es dann zu weiteren größeren
ausbrüchen gekommen wären und licher
weise sind wir ja davon bis jetzt
verschont geblieben und was mich auch
ein bisschen stört auch gerade wenn man
sich viel zeit lässt dieser app zu
entwickeln
jetzt gerade so in der reisezeit die
jetzt wieder beginnt das man dann nicht
die kompatibilität zu den anderen apps
der nachbarländer hat das funktioniert
nicht ja nein also 1 1 die deutsche
kommuniziert nicht mit der
österreichischen oder der spanischen
wenn natürlich zwei deutsche sich auf
mallorca treffen und beide die app
anhaben und und die funktion haben dann
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich dann funktioniert das
ganze natürlich aber wenn jetzt ein
spanier oder engländer dabei ist und die
haben auch eine app
die kommunizieren noch nicht miteinander
und ich hoffe dass das nachgebessert
wird soweit ich weiß ist man dran aber
dass wenn der funktionalität die ich mir
gerade jetzt vor dem sommer deutlich
gewinnt deutlich mehr gewünscht hatte
kevin kühnert das entlarvt auch im
grunde jedes reden auch immer über
europa wieder als sonntagsrede wenn wir
nicht mal das hinkriegen
na ja gut es gibt unterschiedlichen
umgang auch mit diesen apps also in
deutschland hat man ja sehr viel wert
auf datenschutz dabei gelegt weil wir
wissen die debatte ist immer groß und
wenn am ende 70 prozent sagen ich lasse
mir nicht runter weil ich mir unsicher
bin was ich mir da einkaufen dann ist
uns auch nicht geholfen
andere länder haben eine andere
strategie gewählt haben weniger auf
datenschutz gesetzt haben nicht die
dezentrale speicherung der daten gewählt
sondern eine zentrale variante was wir
dafür diskussionen gehabt hätten könnten
sie sich denken dann hätten wir in drei
monaten noch keine krone at ich habe
längst auch so verstanden die zielgruppe
dieser apps sind ja alle menschen über
16 die sich in dem jeweiligen land
aufhalten also ich habe das als appell
verstanden wenn ich mich in dem
urlaubsland jetzt bewegen sollte
innerhalb der eu mir dann immer auch die
örtliche krone at es gibt ja jedem land
dann eine offizielle runterzuladen um
dort wenn ich das möchte an dieses
system angedockt zu sein wird hat
irgendwann echt mühsam und kompliziert
wir müssen reden gibt spannende news zum
thema krone aber ganz grundsätzlich
dieses gefühl herr stürmer der sich da
gerade breit macht ist das etwas was
über unruhig dieses gefühl dass ich da
festsetzt wir haben alles im griff und
im grunde müssen uns nicht weiter
bemühen
ja das ist ein gefühl was sich breit
macht vermutlich was ich skeptisch sehe
bis jetzt ist es eher so dass auch gut
trotz der zahlreichen lockerungen die
zahlen erfreulich niedrig bleiben ich
wie erklären sie sich das weil ich
glaube dass sehr viele menschen sich
trotzdem weiterhin an die vorgaben
gehalten haben und nicht jetzt die neuen
wieder gewonnenen freiheiten ausgenutzt
haben um in altes schema zurückzufallen
ich denke dass sehr viele menschen
weiterhin sich an die hygiene an den
abstand halten kontakte nicht nicht
überreizen den mundschutz auch tragen
wenn notwendig und ich glaube das hat
uns tatsächlich geholfen also mein
respekt ran an die vielen menschen die
dazu beigetragen haben
ich war ein bisschen skeptischer und
freue mich über die situation aber je
länger das gut geht
je länger wir in dieser
sagen wir mal guten situation uns
befinden
je mehr lockerungen noch dazukommen kann
natürlich irgendwann sein dass viele
menschen doch heute sagen jetzt jetzt
reicht's auch jetzt haben wie lange noch
wirklich alles gemacht was sie gesagt
haben und jetzt können wir wieder ein
bisschen mehr und der urlaub verleitet
natürlich auch ein bisschen dazu sich
anders vielleicht zu verhalten als man
es zu hause machen
fällt es ihnen schwer als es als experte
als fachmann da immer weiter den mahner
zu geben und im grunde mittlerweile zu
wirken als als wenn rufer in der wüste
ich habe so ein satz im ohr von henrik
strikt kollege von ihnen aus bonn der
dieser tage sagte so sinngemäß es ist
gerade ein bisschen schwierig die
wahrheit zu sagen ja ja ich habe die
aussage auch gehört und ich glaube da
muss man natürlich mit leben
wenn wir diesen diesen status vertreten
dann ist es halt so und ist stand
natürlich zwei herzen in meiner brust
ich bin ja nicht nur virologe sondern
auch normale menschen und
anführungszeichen und haben natürlich
auch meine einbußen in meinem
alltagsleben damit zu zu verarbeiten
nichtsdestotrotz denke ich trotzdem
man muss immer wieder darauf hinweisen
dass wir uns auf relativ dünnem eis
bewegen und wir sehen ja auch immer
wieder diese ausbrüche die dann relativ
prominent auch nach draußen schießen
berlin-neukölln jetzt gerade wieder als
beispiel vom wochenende wo ein ganzer
wohnblock abgeriegelt wird wo in
mehreren stadtteilen möglicherweise aus
einer quelle basierende infektion hoch
geschossen sind
das ist die situation die wir haben und
die ist nicht weg diese nicht weg peking
ist auch nicht weg haben wir ganze
stadtviertel die mittlerweile wieder
abgeriegelt sind wir schauen sie auf so
einen ausbruch in peking zum beispiel ja
der scheint auch jetzt etwas
dramatischer dargestellt worden zu sein
wie er letztendlich ist es wohl nicht
ganze stadtviertel mit millionen
menschen abgeriegelt worden sondern eher
etwas kleiner geraten
aber das ist auch eine situation wie wir
sie in deutschland sehen da kommt wieder
was hoch das virus ist auch in china in
peking nicht weg es ist immer noch da ob
das jetzt tatsächlich der importierte
lachs ist können wir gleich noch mal
drüber diskutieren aber ich sehe das
auch wieder etwas mit dem blick abwarten
ob es die zweite welle wirklich in
peking wird überzeugt bin ich noch nicht
es kann durchaus sein dass es auch
wieder ein lokaler ausbruch ist aber in
china sind wir ja auch nicht so ganz
sicher ob wir die komplette wahrheit
über die falsch aber lass uns das doch
einmal kurz besprechen ich bin darüber
auch gestolpert der importierte lachs
also auch flachs stellen wo lachs
geschnitten wurde so muss man sagen
schneidebrettern wurden obwohl er
offensichtlich virus gefunden und das
würde ja dann bedeuten da reden wir dann
doch wieder über schmierinfektionen und
solche dinge
das heißt was glauben sie denn was da
dahinter ist wir haben also wenn sie
jetzt für den ich halte es für sehr
unwahrscheinlich weil letztlich müsste
ja in norwegen
jemand der den lachs dort verarbeitet
verpackt hat der müsste das virus auf
diesem weg gebracht haben gute der ist
beim tief gefrorenen zustand kann das
virus sich halten und beim auftauen
wieder infektiös sein aber was ich
mitbekommen habe ist das virus nicht nur
auf einem lack schneidebretter an
mehreren bis zu 40 verschiedenen stellen
gefunden worden
und ich glaube eher dass es eine
infektion ist die tatsächlich von
menschen kommt und nicht unbedingt aus
norwegen jetzt über den lachs nach china
transportiert worden ist auf der anderen
seite da muss man mal abwarten was
daraus sich wirklich bewahrheiten
scheint ein etwas mutiertes virus zu
sein argumentiert notiert ja nicht der
gleiche stamm der ursprünglich in china
sich auf die weltreise gemacht hat da
gibt es aber noch nicht so handfeste
daten dass man wirklich möglicherweise
eine eine rückverfolgung machen kann aus
welcher region der welt möglicherweise
dieses virus nach china gekommen ist was
natürlich sehr spannend wäre das noch zu
verfolgen aber da müssen wir die
nächsten tage mal abwarten was an daten
wirklich veröffentlicht es stand
wirklich spannend wie ein krimi werden
muss man hinter den kulissen noch länger
drüber unterhalten
an welchen stellen so ein virus
möglicherweise mutierten damals über
frankreich gesprochen erinnere ich mich
und dann sagten sie sie glauben dass das
in frankreich auch schon sehr viel
länger kursierte dass möglicherweise ein
anderes thema ist als das was wir
besprochen haben hat das war initialen
mein gedanke dass das wenn das so wäre
dass das möglicherweise so ein versuch
früher versuchte das virus sozusagen war
auf den menschen überzuspringen der
nicht gut geklappt hat weil sich das ja
damals nicht weiter verbreitet hat
ich hab mich dann mal mit dem original
paper beschäftigt und auch mit anderen
kollegen mit christian drosten mich auch
ausgetauscht zu dieser
falken und letztendlich komme ich zu dem
schluss dass er keine eine unsaubere
messung wahrscheinlich waren das ist
eigentlich in frankreich noch keinen
ausbruch tatsächlich schon im november
gegeben haben dürfte
okay wir reden da ich noch ein bisschen
intensiver auch die frage wie diese
viren mutieren was auch dann die suche
nach dem impfstoff so schwer macht und
so weiter seit gestern gibt es plötzlich
wieder die möglichkeit oder gibt es
wieder die möglichkeit nach mallorca auf
die balearen zu fliegen
wie sehen sie das denn also wenn man
diese bilder sieht auch aus diesen
flugzeugen
also wir alle ständig angehalten abstand
zu halten
ja selbst im supermarkt an der theke und
so weiter man wird auch im zweifel in
die schranken gewiesen wenn man jemandem
von hinten zu nahe kommt was auch gut
ist so und dann sieht man nicht nur
diese bilder sondern vor allen dingen
die bilder aus dem flugzeug wie werden
dass gleich sehen wie menschen dicht an
dicht reihen in reihen nebeneinander
sitzen hier
dann würden wir was geht ihnen durch den
kopf wenn sie so was sehen ja mal beim
aller ersten anblick dachte ich auch so
mein gott wir haben ja wir reden über
über abstand halten und jetzt wird man
im flugzeug in den kürzesten abstand
gesessen und man fliegt ja nicht nur
fünf minuten sondern es dauert ja ein
bisschen länger und auch mit sitzen und
fliegen und dann bevor man aussteigen
kann
auf der anderen seite ist es ja wohl so
dass die klimaanlagen in flugzeugen hoch
effektiv sind der luftstrom wohl von
oben nach unten geht vertikalen genauer
filter also hoch effektive
partikelfilter drin sind die wohl auch
kleinste tröpfchen und wären wohl
zurückhalten können und aus der
literatur kennt man auch so ein bisschen
ausbruchs zimmerwände einmal im flieger
was passiert ist weil es beispiel mal in
freelancer genommen dann hat es meistens
die sitzreihen davor und dahinter
getroffen
damals ist man ja nicht mit mundschutz
geflogen das wären dann die klassischen
tröpfchen ich meine jeder von uns will
enders der der geflogen ist irgendeiner
hustet mal also jetzt heute nicht mehr
in der vergangenheit hat ja doch mal
einer gehustet genießen und man freute
sich dann wenn das in der unmittelbaren
nachbarschaft war
und da hat man immer nachweisen können
dass wenn jemand infiziert war
die sitzreihen davor und danach
betroffen waren aber nicht die ganz
hinten oder ganz vorne
was dagegen spricht dass die klimaanlage
dieser erreger
flugzeug und in die ganze kabine
verstreut
also scheint doch sehr effektiv von der
reinigung zu sein und wenn man das in
kombination mit dem mundschutz
letztendlich sich anschaut den mann dann
bitte auch den ganzen flug übertragen
soll ja nicht zwei minuten nach dem
start unternimmt und dann kurz vor der
landung wieder aufsetzt wenn die
stewardess gerade wieder hinguckt dann
halte ich das das fliegen tatsächlich
als die wahrscheinlich und gefährlichste
situation beim urlaub was ist denn für
sie die gefährlichste situation beim
urlaub ja überall davor danach vor allem
aber dann am urlaubsort wenn man dann
doch in eine situation kommt wo man vom
alltag so ein bisschen abstand nehmen
möchte und dann vielleicht eben auch
gerade die angesprochenen
verhaltensmaßnahmen wie abstand halten
nicht jede party nicht jede
veranstaltung mitnehmen die maske doch
immer dann tragen wenn es eng wird dass
man darauf verzichtet das heißt
erstellen urlaubsländern gelten ja auch
corinna regeln dafür ist ja nicht so
also da gibt es genauso die
abstandsregeln es gibt den den die
masken pflicht in hotels wird dafür
gesorgt berichtete das essen so verteilt
wird das niemand auch mit zueinander
setzen muss also insofern finde ich
diese besorgnis kann ich nicht so ganz
nachvollziehen ich glaube dass das sehr
im bewusstsein der menschen in den
vergangenen wochen angekommen ist was
dazu beigetragen hat dass das virus hier
bei uns zum beispiel sich nicht so
ausbreiten konnte wie anderen regionen
will jetzt muss man natürlich bedenken
dass an den urlaubsorten natürlich nicht
nur menschen aus deutschland einreisen
sondern auch aus anderen ländern wo
möglicherweise die disziplin vielleicht
eine andere gewesen ist und wie gesagt
die ich kann es schwere einschläge
stecken würde mir keins einfallen
ehrlich gesagt nicht es gibt doch schon
einige schweden aus dem wm-urlaub man
schwerlich werden doch wiederum
diszipliniert naja hat übrigens viele
schweden
also ich wie gesagt ich bin ein bisschen
ein bisschen ist aufgrund der situation
ist ein bin recht wir haben das alles
sehr gut angeeignet ich kann natürlich
ganz einschätzen wie die situation
wirklich im urlaub ist und würden sie
sich in dieses flugzeug setzen jetzt mal
hand aufs herz tatsächlich ja sie frau
hosen die an kevin kühnert
eher nicht aber ich da wo ich in urlaub
fahre fliegt man auch nicht hin sofern
im zug habe genau aber züge auch nennen
mittlerweile sehr sehr voll
das neue daran ist ja der versucht immer
zu sagen nur einer in so einem doppel
sitzt nur den fensterplatz besetzen das
ist offenkundig schon mal ein
unterschied zu dem was wir hier aus der
kabine sehen ganz klar aber ich habe
auch schon situationen jetzt erlebt in
den letzten wochen pause nur zwölf
kosslick ja also urlaubssituation sie
würde nicht sagen bleibt er lieber zu
hause ich habe das gefühl dass die leute
das von sich aus machen das ist so mein
eindruck
ich habe das gefühl dass verändert das
leben gerade ganz massiv also diese
leichtigkeit mit der wir früher gesagt
haben lasst uns mal kurz nach mallorca
oder egal wohin das ist weg es ist meine
hoffnung dass es bewusster ist und dass
man letztendlich dann auch einfach mit
dem bewusstsein in den urlaub fährt das
ist was besonderes ist ich kann das
absolut nachvollziehen ich habe auch
gestern bilder gesehen wo ein ehepaar
endlich wieder an strand konnte
die hatten das glück dass sie alleine
waren an dem strand zumindest was den
filmausschnitt anging
ob das ist eine einmalige situation das
ist einfach auch nicht zu dicht gedrängt
ist und man kann da hab ich ein lied aus
den 70er jahren hier traten aktuelles
bild für glaubt dass endlich auf der
andern seite ich habe jetzt gerade mit
meiner tochter telefoniert die wollte
eigentlich nach dem abi mit zwei
freundinnen der mallorca reise antreten
die haben sie storniert weil sie sagte
von sich aus das finde ich natürlich
auch eine gute reaktion
wir wollten eigentlich so ein bisschen
was erleben ein bisschen um die häuser
ziehen
das wären wir da nicht machen können
also lassen wir das was ich denke wenn
wir glück haben wird auch aus diesen
urlaub situationen nicht wirklich viel
an uns zurück kommen problem ist
natürlich trotzdem immer dass wir eine
gewisse dunkelziffer haben und das war
wirklich nicht zu hundert prozent wissen
wie es in den einzelnen ländern wirklich
umgesetzt wird
apropos einzelne länder bevor wir gleich
nach brasilien gehen wie schauen sie
schauen sich das ja auch weltweit an wie
bewerten sie die situation in brasilien
ja es ist eine katastrophe eigentlich
und nach den usa das land mit den mit
den schlimmsten ausbrüche mit den
schlimmsten situationen todeszahlen
schnell in die höhe
und natürlich dramatisch also ist auch
sehr schade dass es
soso passieren muss und klar europa ist
im augenblick nicht der hotspot aber
weltweit steigen die infektionszahlen
dramatisch an und da gibt es einige
länder die probleme haben indien zum
beispiel hunde in afrika gehen die
zahlen nach oben wie sie die situation
in indien gerade in den hat ja ganz am
anfang einen ganz ganz harten locker und
gemacht aber sehr regional sozusagen
aber irgendwie scheint denen das auch zu
entgleiten ja ja offensichtlich und das
ist natürlich immer das problem das
virus ist es schwierig zu händeln und
letztendlich ist es so wenn man eine
strategie mal gehabt hat dann sollte man
diese diese harte strategie auch
wirklich konsequent durchziehen und man
sieht ja am beispiel deutschland wenn
man es wirklich konsequent und effektiv
macht und viele leute die menschen auch
mitmachen wie günstig ist oder wie gut
es uns eigentlich geht und so können wir
sehr dankbar für sein dass wir wirklich
so konsequent agieren
das stimmt was das gesundheitliche
angeht ich würde das nicht
unterschreiben was das wirtschaftliche
angeht haben wir kommen später noch mal
zu ab heute gelesen von von mehr als
drei millionen menschen in denen es
wirklich an die existenz gehen das ist
eine enorm hohe zahl also das wird alles
erst wahrscheinlich im herbst richtig zu
verhandeln sein